Dr. Anthony Foushee, the top infectious disease
doctor in the country, has revealed in an
interview over the weekend that he and his
family have been receiving serious threats
as he continues to try to fight the corona
virus pandemic in the United States.
On the same day that we learned about the
threats to Dr. Foushee and his family.
The United States set another single day record
with more than 77000 new corona virus cases,
just shy of 78000 new Corona virus cases.
And the day after we learned that Dr. Foushee
was being threatened and his family was being
threatened.
As we hit a record of single day new cases,
Donald Trump went golfing for the two hundred
and eighty second time of his presidency.
Dr. Foushee saying to David Axelrod on Access
podcast, quote, There are people who get really
angry at thinking I'm interfering with their
life because I'm pushing a public health agenda.
The kind of not only hate mail, but actual
serious threats against me are not good.
I mean, really, is this the United States
of America?
But it's real.
It really is real.
This has gotten so bad that Dr. Anthony Foushee,
a nearly 80 year old infectious disease doctor
who's been working for both Democratic and
Republican presidents for what is it, 40 years
at this point?
It's gotten so bad that Dr. Foushee and his
family now have a security detail, should
be embarrassed.
Donald Trump and his press secretary are out
there talking about, oh, poor patrol is canceled
of a par with you, but some show paw patrol
corona virus is raging and the top guy actually
fighting the virus.
While Trump talks about pop patrol, Dr. Foushee
needs security for himself and for his family
because of threats against them.
And people wonder, why have we?
Why do we have all these cases?
Why do we have 100?
And we're about to cross one hundred and fifty
thousand dead Americans while so many countries
have it under control.
This is why this is why is the world.
Ever going to forgive us for this?
I saw someone on Twitter say in response to
the threats against Foushee and, you know,
everything that's going on.
Too bad we don't have a vaccine for stupidity
while we sort of do.
It's called education, right?
Real quality education with people being taught.
Media literacy and critical thinking.
That is a vaccine against being victim of
disinformation, propaganda.
We're lacking it in a lot of the country.
Now, you know, whenever I say this, educators
write to me, they say, David, you know, we're
doing a good job here.
There.
No doubt there is no doubt that there is plenty
of great education in the United States, but
too much of the United States is lacking it.
We know what the vaccine is to stupidity.
We can produce it in mass quantities, but
we don't invest nearly enough in it as a country.
I'm talking about education here and lots
of parents tell their kids you don't really
need that education.
And this is where we are today.
I made a mistake early on in this pandemic
and I've been reading a bunch of interesting
pieces about it over the last week from others
who made the same mistake.
We didn't think that something so cut and
dry, like a medical crisis, such as the one
we're experiencing, would see the country's
so divided along the typical political lines
where one side says health is the priority.
Listen to doctors.
Take care of others.
Trust in the scientific method, empathy, etc..
And another side would lead.
Protests against masks spread as conspiracy
theories about Dr. Foushee and Bill Gates
show up filming at Wal-Mart to show how patriotic
they are by refusing to wear a mask.
I underestimated it.
I thought this would bring people together
and we would do the right things and put those
stupid political disagreements aside.
But clearly, I was wrong.
And to go back to the Foushee peace, Dr. Foushee
has been thrown to the wolves by this administration,
with Donald Trump criticizing Foushee rather
than criticizing Foundry's detractors.
The White House piled on publishing a document
of what is essentially opposition research
about Dr. Foushee listing things.
The White House released to the media a document
saying, look at all the stuff out you got
wrong.
Well, what about Trump saying fifteen cases
will soon be zero?
There is no accountability for that.
What about Trump saying all of the things
that he has said?
Can you imagine Dr. Foushee and Bill Gates,
two of the people pouring time and money in
Gates's case into solving infectious disease
for no personal gain?
Bill Gates donating, what is it, hundreds
of millions at this point to vaccination and
dealing with disease?
Dr. Foushee is nearly 80.
He's a high risk individual, which he says
is why he's not stepping on a plane or going
to a restaurant.
And yet he's seemingly working 24/7 and they
are attacked.
Conspiracy theories created about them has
about one third of the country gone functionally
insane.
Defining functional insanity is tough, but
the gist of it is if you're functionally insane,
you can basically exist in society in a semi
normal way.
Like you could probably hold a job.
For example, you're keeping your kids alive
well enough to raise them to adulthood, that
they may have some weird ideas, but you're
keeping them alive.
But then in practice, they live believing
completely delusional things like Dr. Foushee
is helping Bill Gates as population control
wet dream agenda by planning to RFID chip
people with a vaccine or masks are making
me lose my rights or depriving me of oxygen.
Or it's reasonable to scream at a Costco employee
because I don't want to wear a mask.
And I think coronaviruses effect is a hoax.
Is there a sort of functional insanity here
that we have to deal with?
Unclear.
But I feel terribly for Dr. Foushee.
And again, is the world going to forgive us
for this?
This has been one of the largest mishandling
of anything.
I mean, listen, Katrina was a disaster the
way that George Bush handled Katrina.
There is no excuse whatsoever.
But compare the scale of what we're dealing
with now.
And to call this trumps Katrina.
It understates actually what's going on without
in any way minimizing the absolute disaster
that was George W. Bush's handling of Katrina.
I don't even know what to compare it to.
At this point in time and again today, probably
by the time you hear this, we likely will
have surpassed the hundred and fifty thousand
death milestone.
I don't know if we deserve to be forgiven,
unfortunately, for what this administration
has done or better said, not done in response
to this virus.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this with the latest from Portland,
where the mayor has actually been teargassed,
if
you can believe that.